[Musique]
tuer le chef des armées mais ta
popularité est au plus bas dans les
sondages
tu veux savoir si tu sera réélu à la
présidence de la république française
ton prénom et françois est au nom de
famille est un pays qui commence par eau
est finie parlant d' envoi mandat au 17
17 2010 est suivi de ton programme
politique complet en fichier pdf et tu
saura si oui ou non tu pourra de nouveau
diriger l'état membre là au 17 17 2017
et si elle me mentait je ne sais pas si
je peux lui faire confiance
tu veux savoir c'est ta meuf est
originaire du poitou envoie poitou voip
ou suivi de son certificat de naissance
et d'une photocopie recto verso de son
livret de famille aux 16 17 ou à tous
mais au heat et ou aux 16 17
j'ai envie qu'on prenne à l'appart
ailleurs
je veux savoir tu possèdes sur le tour
la lauze envoie même aux toits qu'on
puisse très brève turc devra peut-être
un demi litre de staline dédicacé par
akhenaton en personne envoie mais aux 66
13 trade se donne appels surtaxés sous
réserves de stocks disponibles
tu veux savoir si tu assures en
arithmétique envoie huit fois 47 plus
racine 228 divisé par trois pistes sur
deux le tout au carré le temps occupe au
62 17 et u saura enfin si tu touches
tabbee en calcul mental en voit le
résultat de cette opération aux 62 17
attention prix d'un appel local depuis
un poste fixe dans le montant est
supérieur ou égal à 1 euro ou ben est un
anti naturel compris entre 0 et plus
l'infini lusage de la calculatrice n'est
pas autorisé hier j'ai oublié mon divy
code et aujourd'hui je zappe
l'anniversaire de ma meuf galère je dois
avoir un problème au cerveau
tu veux savoir si ta mémoire de feu des
faux envois mémoire ou 8 41 41 76 17 89
03 45 53 0 1 243 511 9 117 81 8 981 71
67 41 42 87 1365 11 ans voit mais moir
ont 8 41 41 76 17 89 03 45 53 0 1 243
511 9 117 81 8 981 71 67 41 42 87 1365
11 11
[Musique]
en effet tous les carrés sont des
losanges mais tu oublies losange sont
pas des carrés alors soyez gentils bad
amalgame bon ce que je propose peut-être
pour mettre tout le monde d'accord
on va refaire ce sketch en essayant de
ne blesser personne
yahoo